Nope,
Dan,
let's go on to Tomas hops and I
don't something about trouble.
We're not everybody does.
Uh,
I've kind of history of ideas scores.
I give you an overview of the individual,
uh,
whom you were reading from. Um, and uh,
uh, uh, [inaudible], uh,
some sense of the historic
times they lived in. Well,
occasionally I get negative comments
in my course evaluations for this.
People want just to talk about the
past, but they have to know, um,
uh, that are some people
who like it to see, wow,
this is how Tomas hops.
So that four, I still
be doing this. I think.
What have you tried to do?
Yes.
Go very fast through the slides.
It should have my cake and eat right
and showed us sleep in that historical
context and the street and is all swollen
up on the board.
You can't go back to that.
And then there'll be
stopped that this week. Uh,
almost hops and, uh, uh, bad.
Their foundations of modern
social for good stock pops or not.
That's a Mash Tun. Uh,
even some other courses I
bake them about that even eat
be Sundays. Audio almost pops. Yes.
The first I believe the foundation.
So mother silence,
um,
uh [inaudible] and the formula.
Then you stream the controversial speaker
and that's all very important issues.
Yeah. All steel. That'd be
good.
Or are you by nature?
I think that will be handled crowd
one day
started that in the discussion sections.
Got Our Napo in buddy border issues.
Almost false screen.
I do try to be low impact later.
Social Sam Smith or Nesha on Brian on the
next eight or and audios.
Okay.
So this is sort of sparse and a that'd
be just that if he could talking about
his life. I mentioned production.
You like the most boring.
Do you invest sport? I also mentioned
that the Spanish was a baker.
He had actual young,
he's fine. He's learned.
She man places in a cemetery.
Absolutely.
We'll know by that time.
So we have to skip and this,
that and the food must us behind me,
the kid off and uncle
when what's actually then
go off. So you saw a peptide.
Ooh,
I'd be back to Oxford.
They might go and call them in other ways.
Uh,
graduated became a future of feeding
cabin vishuddha sector as we begin.
And
then France and Italy.
It's very important because he,
that Med gone the literal,
it's absolutely going by getting battle.
And the quizzes,
Stein,
I already mentioned by the
halts kettles be classified and,
but basically it's even fellow would be
classified as a social science is you
boast as the much a map mission.
I get the big advancement,
I love all sorts of,
made me be quote unquote the sciences.
Now. Uh, uh,
he had close association, uh, person,
you'll be a fence faith and it
was Francis Bacon in the groups,
uh, fences fake come, uh,
plus a few awesome bird.
I haven't rejected of youngest
book value on logic system.
Um, uh, which basically was a,
you have this system a stop out,
some major assumptions.
So we thought shows that alone.
It's the most open ecosystem.
As I said,
well I build these scores by stopping.
That's his bacon.
It does become in some ways
is the founding father of
modern science is because
he said every scientific investigation,
she'll start the induction from central
observation and what you observe,
you shoot off a suit.
It does exist.
What I've done for II advocate at the
methodology is was exactly the opposite of
Yeti slow Pallium methodology,
which trust document the FOP adoption.
But now that he most spending cools
the affiliated good Cavendish and had a
great deal of impact on hops
initially we'll eventually,
hops of change actually is mine
and the other they suspend
you left the stem time.
That is uh, uh, and, and uh, uh,
investigate natural science
in particular because the most important
sport for hops from Dadi level.
If you learn, and I'll turn
up who bacon's inductive Maca,
uh,
got a little awkward and methodologies
by it and watch social scientists to bed
who be in normal social science,
subscribed Neiman's.
That's was the methodology bunk to
the level a resolute called positive.
She got the math that from
struck the deduction, right?
You have some initial hypotheses,
then you'll move observation,
central observation and froze
the central observation you made,
inductions that you made back
and you test your hypotheses.
That's how I'd be in bed.
And this is what my bacon
learn from garden level and uh,
adapted this methodology.
And now this is a really,
they card, uh, you know,
one of the greatest philosophers
of the times and of all times the,
they now as compared to something
like call. Well, isn't it right?
Isn't it
he only man that he separated the
soul and body from each other and hops
rejecting this idea?
Uh,
because he suggested that in fact they
were engaged in a big debate on optics.
What,
what we do see,
and he hops was advocating that there
must be a real object whose movement we
see,
what we actually can see.
So he rejected the
dualism and then he wrote,
I mentioned very briefly,
he's try logix that quarter.
This is about the human body,
the homeowner, about men.
And finally the Seaver about society.
I see this is formidable and something
which APIs are great deal to social
scientists today, right? To try
to develop a theory of social
society,
which begins actually the biology,
the biological processes,
and build it up gradually from biology
to understanding of the social,
the individual, and from the
individual to understand society.
That's highly controversial. There are
many social scientists who rejected,
but today that are many social scientists
were greatly attracted to this and be
see an emergence today are for
sciences and social scientists.
Well,
a hops entered politics as a royalist.
Um, uh, uh, then, uh, uh,
really I'm Kevin Bisch, uh,
entered politics and in
fact harps, uh, translated.
I also mentioned to kitty
this and basically because
to kitty does express some
skepticism about the democracy in Athens
and he was greatly skeptical about the,
uh, the democracy. Um, and
the, uh, uh, believe the, uh,
the need for a strong central authority.
Where are these world very troubled times,
a troubled times and religious conflict.
So I skipped this one because I know
you are all very familiar with British
history,
but it all started with Henry,
the aides who had a very trouble
the matador relationship. Right?
Year three, vives, uh, divorced
Vonn executed the second one, uh,
in search for Assan from
funnel, one of his, um,
his wife's. Um, but in
the process of divorcing,
he split from the Roman Catholic Church.
And that's from Church of England.
Uh, immersion. That's how, um, uh, uh,
England became a rather
standoffish a sword. Uh,
um, well, uh, again, as I said, I,
I skipped this one and one, they,
this is a, uh, the eldest daughter,
um, are from Henry ator. Mary,
the first call, the bloody Mary.
Uh, she inherited the throne. Uh,
she was crying, uh, to, uh, uh,
um, uh, establish a, um, uh, uh,
Roman Catholicism or Bart had to resign.
There was too much resistance against it.
So he had to resign. And the,
uh, give the Troon, uh, to, uh,
his younger sister, um,
our lizard that, um, uh,
and this is screen Elisabet.
Um, and Trina Elisabetta,
uh, uh, was at the time of, uh,
puritanism under a great deal of pressure
of puritans who wanted to get rid of
Catholics all together,
uh,
from government in England became this
became a very important issue. Uh,
later on. And New haven has his
spirit and connections. Uh, uh,
anybody is from Davenport College.
Nobody's from that are important.
Oh my goodness.
So naughty are purely turns around
here. There are, that's a shame.
Anyway, this was a reverend
John Davenport. Um,
he was a puritan who
settled, um, in, uh, uh,
new haven with his followers
in 16 dirt the eighth. And, uh,
uh,
already of course in I think 1703,
the puritans created this institution
and they were basically running this
institution until the late 19th century.
Not Anymore.
Okay. Um, now, uh,
there will be a great deal of
conflicts between, uh, you know, yeah.
Mary was called the
virgin clean. Well, uh,
whether she was a virgin or
not, it's unclear, but she's
clearly had a lot of, uh,
a very close friendship, uh, via
to value as a man in her life.
But she never married and
never gave birth to a charge.
He was actually a very good cleaner, a
smart, good, good, good, good, clean,
uh, by, uh, you know, the
challenges of the time. Um,
uh, uh, but, uh,
she was the last one and
died be the Assan. Uh, uh,
and, uh, then, uh, uh, the, uh,
the crown went over to the,
to the stewards and they
were total disaster.
James first was ordered the disaster and
Charles the first was real disaster and
they vote in collision of course,
with parliament.
And there was a constant war in England,
civil war,
culminating in 42.
And finally charts.
The first was executed in 49. Um, uh, and,
uh, Oliver [inaudible]
came to power. Now, um,
are here I give you a picture of
the execution of Charles First.
If you don't believe
it, you can see it. Uh,
well hops that got into some
trouble at that time. Um,
uh, uh, uh,
because he was too close to the
royalists and he had to flee England,
uh, in CC and 40, uh, a
head of time and he van,
uh, uh, to, uh, live in, in Paris.
And he was very close that
to the is exercise. And in,
uh, 51, he completed his
major book, Leviathan.
What review we'll be talking
about in a minute. Uh, um, well,
Leviathan became an
extremely controversial book.
It was very controversial in his
times. Uh, became, uh, actually, uh,
a big hot topic in the 19th century and
it's a very hot topic in the last 30 or
40 years because a lot of economists and
political scientists who are interested
in rational choice theorists discovered
in Tomas hops the first rational choice
choice, the earliest it's extruding.
He's a bonder fully lucid mind.
And if you read the text and
you know enough mathematics,
you could do a lot of his propositions
in mathematical equations,
what all else and economists want to do,
right?
It must be true if you can put
it into an equation right now,
that's what certainly Thomas Hobbs is
available to do because of the extremely
lucidity, uh, of, of,
of, of his mind. Now,
it was definitely a controversial book
also for the royal royalist because in 51
hops, and if you're talking
about this in great detail,
was considering that probably
people should be allowed
to transfer their loyalty
to an owner knew or authority
which offers safety. Right?
And that's what the royal is,
did not want to hear that crumb val
actually can become a legitimate ruler.
And that's what in a day,
um, uh, the book, um, um,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
Leviathan, uh, uh,
foreshadows so he better had to skip
out of Paris and go back to London.
This is the first edition
of Leviathan, uh, 51,
and this is about the idea that people
are by nature evo and we need an all
powerful sovereign to avoid
the seat of war of uh, uh,
everyone against everyone else.
Powerful proposition. Again,
I would think probably half of the people
in this classroom then really think
hard about it.
Do believe hops argument.
Half of them would be violently
opposed to the argument, right?
So it's a very nice topic to
have heated discussions in.
Uh, the uh, um, uh, uh,
discussion sections there via turn,
uh,
is a sea monster, the state
or the silver room. Uh,
we need to keep order as such.
Okay.
There were a great deal of
controversies around him. Um, uh,
he actually was publishing rather new
trust stuff, only attacking universities,
which is over as a good
thing to do. Right. Um, uh,
but then in a 1660,
the monarchy was restored and charge the
second, the son of Charles De Fund, uh,
first became king hops was invited back
to the court and it looked like if you'd
be just fine right now as a royalist
not so because in [inaudible] 66,
there was a fire in London.
And because of this fire,
some people believe that this fire was a,
the revenge of God because
of the sin full New York,
Not New York, London. Right. And, uh,
they were therefore trying
to find the guilty long.
And who was there?
Of course Tomas hops with his is maride.
Uh,
no. So, so how is that
a journal life possible?
This must be an Ati is
his book should be burned,
if not himself.
So they did not burn his book and himself,
but you know,
he certainly was out of
grace and died in 79.
He was greatly admired
in continental Europe,
but was very controversial in England.
And Val,
if you don't believe there was a fire
in London, here is the proof, right?
That is the great fire of London 66,
which by you know, look like
Los Angeles to me, right? Uh,
okay.
About 3000 people right there.
The fire brigade was not as effective
as today is in southern California.
Okay. Now that's about, uh, uh,
the person and the times,
I think extremely for my,
as far as I'm concerned,
extremely important to
understand this, uh, the Virg,
um, if, uh, if you know the
times when he, he lived in,
okay.
All right, so now let
me go on and, uh, uh,
dark too,
uh,
Leviathan
[inaudible].
This is the first edition of Leviathan
which came out in [inaudible] 60 and 50.
Vaughn, uh, in cure big volumes.
Each one was 500 pages long.
Now this is the structure of the book.
The first spot is on the man.
Uh, uh, uh, and, uh,
the first few chapters are
about the mechanisms because
of Galileo or hops of us
are obsessed with the idea of motion.
Um,
so he described the biological
motion, spot moves, man,
senses, imagination, speech reason
and so on and so forth. Uh, the,
and the chap just sits is out bond
chapter. It is about empathize,
desires,
every versions and fierce and the theory
of voluntary action have you talk about
this. This is really very
insightful, very important,
a very great deal of impact on
contemporary times. And I hope that, uh,
you can also relate to it individually.
And then a chapter seven to 11 is,
uh,
uh, the relationship between
people as Sawcha. Uh,
and then the final, the, the state
of nature and the two laws of nature.
We've, you'll have to talk about
this in greater detail. So,
uh, the bar two is about common Val's, uh,
it's about really the first
theory of politics. Um, uh,
uh,
the rights and duties of the
governments and the subjects.
Uh,
there are some very interesting arguments
here that actually the [inaudible]
also have duties,
not only simply rights.
And then part three and four,
a offer,
some theological justification.
What he does, uh,
bizarre chapter, part three and four. Uh,
I think very the red, or at least
I see very few citations to it.
So what are the major themes of the book?
Uh,
first about the theory of human nature?
the second one is the
relationship between, uh, uh,
nature and sort of the
theory of social contract,
uh, hops is really the first
of the contact areas, right?
Who are advocates that what brings
society together is a social contract.
If you want to understand.
So Saturday you have to understand
that we have contracts with each other.
And then finally the theory of the
Silverado, right? Uh, the major desire,
the essence of hops work years to try
to find an identifiable Silverman,
right?
He lived in turbulent times when you
did not know who the silver on is.
Is this the king is the landlord,
are these disease,
the burgers? Is this the parliament?
Who on earth is the stubborn,
he wanted to find one identifiable
silver and we can all agree this is the
proper source of law, right?
That's what he was obsessed with.
Okay. Uh, so let me then move
on and about human nature.
What are the themes here now? Uh,
one important argument is
that men will deliberate,
deliberate between appetites and
aversions and as a result it will act
voluntarily. Well, it's
a fascinating issue.
An issue. The cannot get
red out of our hair. Uh, um,
well when I was in your age,
the all of us were there
mentally debating the question,
do we have the two, three, three
bill? Or if you don't have reveal,
right,
our action is over a debtor mind.
This is exactly the question of what the
hops is talking about and develops the
idea of voluntary action,
which is kind of half day between absolute
Freeville and complete determination,
right? The idea is that
we are driven by appetite,
by desires.
Vivio talking discourse later
on about Zigmund. Right? Right.
We were stuffing you about derives right,
that our drives and have each
makes us move these out about hops,
God appetite few century
before they won't fry.
But then he said they also have aversions.
We have fears,
the are these what we want,
but we have fares that we won't
be able to achieve what they want.
And therefore we have to somehow
negotiate out between our desires,
appetites,
and our fears or aversions.
And what comes out is voluntary action.
It's weak.
Have a choice, right?
We have to measure up,
but the price of our action VOB and then
we decide where that it is worse stupid
this brass or it is not
averse to pay this price. Uh,
so I see somebody whom
I designed a great deal.
I thought it would be
a great partner for me,
but in order to approach that person
and to say, can I have a date?
It has risks because it
may say go to hell. Right?
And I don't want to be rejected. Right.
I have fears that Ivy will be rejected.
So I've even been measuring
God. Right. And some of you,
if you aren't in such a situation,
if you since that the answer will be no,
you don't place the phone call. Right?
And you'll, you'll never get that person.
Right. The fare over rules, right.
The appetite or others
will say, heck, you know,
it's a no then ivy or try a second time.
I've you're trying to curve time and if
it is no, the third time that I give up.
Right? Okay. So this is
voluntary action, right?
This is freedom,
right?
You are free to decide whether
you want to try it again, right?
Whether you want to
achieve your appetites.
And then the second point
is maybe of sea power.
The essence of human nature is
that we are striving for power.
Again, an issue, very good issue to
discuss at the discussion section.
Again,
I think the half of the class we
probably agree with hopes that people are
actually trying to dominate others.
Others will see we are much
more beneficial than three
are actually nice people.
You don't want to dominate.
Well, voc his argument for it,
he said actually. And the
last point is, you know,
if we want to survive vivio
need an all powerful silver.
So, um, voluntary action. Uh,
he actually said that
are two kind of motions.
One motion is what he
calls vital emotions.
And these are stuff like,
you know,
a food that we want to have food or
something and that is what he costs.
Well it sounds stage today,
animal motions,
but this is what I think is a better
called voluntary motion. So, um,
it'd be which actually has something
to do with the appetizer or desires or
aversions and how to deal with this.
So let me just speak about
appetites and the versions. Again,
I don't want to read the texts
savvy or put it on, um, uh, um, uh,
on, on the Internet for you. Uh, it
just describes what I have said, right?
That we all have appetites, we
have designers, we have needs,
and in order to satisfy our needs,
it always has costs and therefore
they have to figure it out.
Whether it was the cost for us
to satisfy that need, right?
And therefore we have a
certain degree of freedom.
We don't be conned to do
whatever we want to do, right?
Because we may not have the resources
to afford it or they have one,
we'd want to have many things.
And then we will have to have,
prioritize what we want to
have more and spend more on it.
As you can hear, right.
Hops is very close through,
but later on becomes the Utilitarians,
right?
Very close to what Adam Smith,
we'll argue in his economic theory or
what Joe Stewart, Neil have you represent.
It's uh, um, in, in, in his, uh,
utilitarian is or for the at that safe,
but what most economists today believe,
right?
Who called themselves neoclassical
economists or who identified themselves as
rat choice, right? Or
rational choice economies.
All political scientists or sociologists
for the sake that are some sociologists
who also subscribed to
restaurant of choice or I,
this is also very lovely liberation
and the bill. And he said,
well, when we have designers
and we have a version,
that's when we actually
beginning to figure it out.
We liberate what on earth is verse for us.
And the end of this deliberation,
we have a bill redesign.
I go for it.
I want that to date.
Right?
Or we decide I don't want it because
the costs are too high. Okay.
And this is what we call the Ville.
Your will will be that you
decide I go for it or you decide,
no, that's not verse for
me. It would be silly.
I make out a cloud out of me.
I just don't do it right.
That's the veal well, uh, about power.
The power is on ending,
right.
He said that is right.
A general inclination for
us to seek power, power,
influence on other people.
And he said,
this is not nothing evil about it.
It is necessary because if you want to
survive the veal have to try to exercise
influence on address.
We have to seek power as such extremely
important idea which foreshadows
especially uh,
uh,
Nicha and Max Faber who comes
up later in this course.
Well then he comes a very
interesting argument about equality.
Very exciting argument.
He,
he is one of the very first philosophers
who claims that the are all born equal.
Now for you,
this is of course of years but was
not obvious in 1651 that people,
mobiles and serves
slaves and slave holders.
We are all born equal.
Uh,
and he said in factor also
extremely important that
they are ever equal actually
in strengths.
Because even the weaker person,
we Casperson has the capacity
to kill the strongest one.
I even David can kill goal go out.
Yeah,
right.
But he said the same goes intellectually
and in fact intellectually we are even
more equal than by physical plower.
So that's Sal's Mandra fool and
you probably all agree with it,
but then he makes a very controversial
point and probably that are some people
in this room who agree with him,
but others probably or disagree with it,
namely he said,
but comes from this equality
is this unending fight that
because we designed the
same thing and he operates with the
scarcity assumption that what is desirable
is actually scares if you're
five to each other. Right?
And we can fight each other because we
had equal because we cal can kill each
other. You can outsmart each other. Uh,
this is a very unusual argument,
right?
He is a very ironic guy right now.
He always says things,
but you may not want to hear right.
And this is something what, who believes
in equality do not want to hear that.
In fact,
equality can be interpreted as the reason
for social conflict rather than the
solution for social conflicts. That
that is his argument. Very interesting.
Very unusual. Right, and again,
probably the closest to Nicha
as we will see they are.
Then we have, this is I, this
is, I won't read it, save it.
This is the page you want to trend
because for the rest of your life,
if you ever Vonn thrive to site the harps,
this is the citation,
right? And namely that the,
if we will be therefore be in a war of
everyone against everyone else for the
above reasons.
Now about the question of social contract,
a veil, he operates with this idea
of state of nature. Then they,
we'll talk a lot about this because in
among the most of the social theorist
found founding fathers
of social theorists,
there is a debate what is the original
nature of humans and it's controversial
that that this is a useful concept
at all the state of nature.
But he did believe in this.
Well, there are really
two basic laws of nature.
One Law of nature is that you are full,
forbidden.
What is harmful to you,
right? You have to post.
So self interest.
He had again,
you see the rational choice
theory speaking, right?
People are self interested and this is
the law of nature that we should be self
interested, right? We have to do
everything in order to preserve our life.
But that is a second law of nature.
You are used and this requires that
we what you would not do a yeah.
Not to do others.
What you would not want them to do to you.
Right?
This is again,
you may want to save these citation.
Very important citation for shadows,
major theorists of ethics,
which gum many,
many years or decades
or centuries after him,
particularly Emmanuel Kant, right? Uh, uh,
and his categorical in better diverse.
Okay?
Uh,
well does in the state of nature,
if there are no restraints,
that is no civilization.
That's a very interesting idea,
right?
That pressure limiting the
state of nature is necessary.
This is again, for shadows. Absolutely.
Zigman fried and his
theory of civilization,
the civilization comes out
of the repression of drive.
So rather than satisfaction of,
of drives,
if whatever you all need
is immediately satisfied,
there is no civilization.
Civilization comes from software inks,
right?
For from suppressed desires.
That's when you go back and you create
great pieces of art or you become a great
scientist because you suppress
your sexual and other desires,
right? That's, you know, it's
all of us from suffering.
They're great products of
humankind are coming from right.
That's what he's saying. And that's
of course what Zigmund fried view say.
Okay. Uh, there are the two
laws of nature and again,
I don't want to elaborate on it.
This is quite obvious.
He said that is the elementary
a law of nature. The right,
that's we have to do whatever is
necessary for sackcloth action.
And the elder one is that we
actually should consider others,
but others will do bell
and then the contract now,
but follows from the second
law of nature, uh, is that uh,
we pulled our rights as
side and transferred it to,
uh,
orders that uh,
these chance food of rights,
uh,
is something that is
some reciprocity there.
We give up some rights and
he gets something in exchange
protection or safety or
something as such.
Um,
and when the transferred
these rights to somebody else,
this is what is called the
covenant or social contract.
This is as far as I can tell,
this is the first formulation of
the theory of social contract.
Uh, it's not quite the
theory of social contract,
but we will read from a law or from
Rousseau because he said to again,
controversial comments,
one that in fact that contract we
entered by fear is also obligatorily.
Uh,
just because we were forced into
a contract out of fear does not,
does not mean that we can walk out
of this contract whenever we want to.
Right. So it's very much state to
school. He's a conservative guy.
I think it has to be understand,
right? He's deeply conservative.
And then he also said that in fact,
a former corner contract
makes void a later contract.
So that is no divorce. The
put in this way, right?
Once you'll swear. Do you
know that? Well, uh, uh,
I save it you until via live.
That's about it, right? Uh,
that is no new contract,
which avoids it.
They'll, uh, uh, now, uh,
very briefly about the power of the
silver and it's power is to produce safety
to the people, right? He
lives in unsafe times,
so he wants safer safety.
But obedience is only due to the extent
the silver and can deliver the safety.
And if it cannot lie, charge
the first couldn't, well,
you could redraw your,
um, uh, um, uh,
obedience to you. Loyalty
from it. Okay. Now, uh,
uh, what is, uh, important, uh,
in his time to find out who the sewer and
ears and the silver Sudan actually can
be? Uh, and, uh, uh, I just, uh,
point out two words from the
citation can be transferred on war,
man,
right?
The king or a pawn one assembly of man.
That's I think extremely important
though he was very strongly in favor of
absolutism.
He did consider right that the silver
and can be a properly assembled body of
man. What, how they view
be properly assembled.
He doesn't have the faintest study or
doesn't have the guts to say it right.
It will become much more clear in
lock and particularly in Rousseau,
uh, where the sewer and ears
and it becomes of course,
crystal clear in the
American constitution,
we start re the people,
right?
That's the silver one is uh,
in hops Stein,
it was not quite we the people,
but he did consider that it may
not be the royal, the royalty,
the king right now, the,
the sewer industry have
duties. Uh, uh, uh,
the, uh, office of the Silverman, uh,
has to procure safety of the people.
And he said he adds to this extremely
important that it is not bear
preservation. It has to give
more than just survival, uh, uh,
as such, and therefore you can expect to
the server and to deliver this and the,
the silver than does not deliver.
You can, we drove right? You royalty.
So even though he is, uh,
uh, a theorist of absolutism,
he does see you ride the
need and possibility that
you withdraw your loyalty and
new transfer it to,
I got king right to a good
silver and as such, um,
uh,
well the question is also what are the
good laws are the people say good laws
are the laws which are good for
the, and uh, and he said it,
this is extremely important,
but I, I highlighted it.
It is not so not through that good laws
serve only the silver and the good laws
should serve the people. Uh, well, uh,
and this is the end of it.
What are his contributions and
what are his shortcomings? Well,
his emphasis is on peace and order,
right?
But what he does not consider that
the silver and might abuse his power.
And this will be the big criticism
of hops by later theorists,
particularly by law Vivia seat
or that events day, right?
Rory is primarily considered by the
possibility that the silver and may abuses
power
they'll,
and then he actually does
not develop as a result,
you theory how power
can be held in checks.
That is no theory of checks and balances.
That is one in hops and even one
more developed in Montesquieu.
And the American constitution does not
come from hops or the cops for comes from
Loc.
And particularly from Montesquieu.
Montesquieu is the one which
defined that checks and balances,
which entered the American constitution.
They're all,
he was an apple or genetical.
Theories of an enlightened absolute
is not any absolute isn't right.
Uh, he was, uh, against
the real monsters, uh,
as I ordered it demonstrated as a result,
he was not acceptable to the monarchs
because he put too much limitations on
their powers,
but he was not acceptable to the
emergent bourgeois class because it that
rebooted too much power to the
monarch. And therefore, you know,
nobody really liked hops,
but the, uh, nobody liked.
And you may not like him.
What is impossible is to eat more him,
right? You have to listen to him. Well,
see you Wednesday and Thursday
in discussion sections.